[Music]
on this monday night
new coved 19 vaccine deals the feds
secure millions of more doses on one
condition
canadians will have access to the doses
they need
why some experts feel canadians will be
left waiting for the shot
what came toppling down
is going back up the debate over
memorializing canada's
first prime minister peace in the air
the historic journey for israel and the
united arab
emirates and who's calling it shameful
plus this year's
must-have school supply i always wanted
one that reflected my personality
the best masks for kids
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with the race to develop an
effective coven 19 vaccine and the new
efforts to ensure canadians get access
the federal government says it has
signed deals with american drug
companies
novovax and johnson and johnson to
reserve doses of their vaccines
if they're deemed successful similar
deals are already in place with pfizer
and moderna
the government says altogether these
deals could result in tens of millions
of vaccine doses for canadians
but first they must prove to be safe and
effective
and that appears to be a ways off
michael couture reports on the push to
secure a vaccine and the politics at
play
in politics optics is everything so the
image of the prime minister visiting a
company that could help manufacture a
covid19 vaccine
should inspire confidence the reality is
canada is in the middle of difficult
negotiations with a number of companies
to reserve a supply of vaccines or even
have a chance of getting
a successful vaccine there's obviously a
lot more work to go
as there are many many different
organizations and
companies researching vaccines but our
focus is going to be on making sure that
when a vaccine is developed
canadians can have access to it as
quickly as possible
a promising collaboration with chinese
firm cansino biologics went sour
when china refused to sign export
permits for the potential vaccine
government officials point out canada
still has four other deals
with major pharmaceutical companies
which could guarantee us
tens of millions of doses it's fully
realistic that
some of these vaccines may never end up
making it to market
but the more vaccines that we have
access to the more likely we are
to to start vaccine rollout programs
some infectious disease experts believe
canada is late to the game
the u.s inked a deal with pfizer this
summer for up to 600 million doses of a
vaccine
weeks later canada secured up to 20
million doses
leading some to believe will be at the
back of the line
canadians are going to wait months
longer than americans and europeans to
get their shots
and that's because our government has
left it very late
in the day not true says the minister in
charge of procurement
within the contracts that we are
negotiating we have built in delivery
dates
as early as first quarter of 2021
and one member of the federal vaccine
task force says securing the right
vaccine
is their top priority we don't want
a winter to go by without having access
to vaccine
if there is one that has shown to be
promising
but that's only after the vaccine
receives proper approval from health
canada which the prime minister said
will not be rushed contrast that with
the united states
where the food and drug administration
has opened the door to approving a
covet-19 vaccine
before phase 3 trials are complete
robin michael good you're in ottawa
thanks mike
the federal government has extended a
loan program for canadian companies
struggling during the pandemic
the canada emergency business account
now goes until october 31st
the program helps small businesses and
not-for-profits
finance expenses that can't be avoided
or deferred
under the program struggling companies
qualify for loans up to forty thousand
dollars
of which ten thousand dollars is
forgiven if it's repaid by twenty twenty
two
finance minister christian freeland says
the federal government will also expand
eligibility to businesses that handle
transactions
through personal bank accounts in
ontario tonight the government is facing
a legal fight over its back to school
plans
with just weeks ago until classes resume
the province's four teachers unions have
filed an appeal with the labor relations
board
they say the government has failed to
address their health and safety concerns
the premier says his government is doing
its best doug ford accuses the unions
of just wanting to cause trouble i'm i'm
begging now
for the teachers unions to work with us
we have done absolutely everything
everything everything that they've
wanted everything that the
the uh the advice from the health table
everything from the ministry of health
we're sparing nothing every idea
possible
we're putting into the classroom
next door in quebec class is already
back in session
french language schools opened last week
and today english language students had
their first day in class
mike armstrong has more on how it's gone
so far and the challenges
that lay ahead the first day of school
tends to mean some butterflies but this
year's a little different
covid19 means kids have been out of
classes for more than
five months and they're going back with
masks
it's okay i'm like i'm used to it now
like i have to wear everywhere so it's
okay
now not everyone's making that nervous
walk back to school
the english montreal school board has
had about 400 applications for students
to do classes remotely from home
parents have to submit a doctor's note
explaining the reason
they have a health issue that makes them
or a household member
vulnerable to covet quebec's french
schools
started up again last thursday but even
though this was literally only day three
there have already been coveted 19 cases
in several schools
at one high school 55 students have been
told to self-isolate for two weeks
we are investigating every case every
outbreak
and we intervene in the first 24 hours
at this school northwest of montreal
four teachers have tested positive
and another 20 teachers have been told
to stay home as a precaution
that's meant some students are in class
being taught by a teacher
on video conference
it's bizarre she says it's different
we'll have to get used to it
while one teachers union is raising
concern about teachers moving around
it's not uncommon for substitutes or art
teachers for example to go from school
to school
even in the same day could they spread
covet 19.
this union leader says they don't want
to repeat what happened in the health
care system
where staff carried kovid 19 from one
senior's residence to another
one issue they've already tried dealing
with at this school is crowded hallways
they're trying to stagger breaks to cut
down on contact between students
well this is a photo taken monday that
shows there's still
room for improvement mike armstrong
global news
de montang quebec keeping kids in school
will depend on whether covet 19
infections are under control
today quebec's premier pleaded with his
province to do their part
and follow the rules we need to get back
to the discipline we had in the spring
we don't want to close our businesses
and above all we don't want to close our
schools
quebec recorded the most new cases of
any province today 140 more people
tested positive
ontario alberta and bc each recorded
more than 100 new cases global news has
uncovered explosive allegations
the rcmp ignored repeated warnings about
a suspected mole
cameron orders a former high-ranking
civilian intelligence official
is facing criminal charges accused of
preparing to share classified
information
now a new lawsuit alleges those working
under him complained about his strange
and controlling behavior
two years before his arrest abigail
beeman has the exclusive details
three rcmp employees allege the
workplace culture
rapidly deteriorated in march 2016
following cameron ortiz's director
general appointment
they say very early on ortis began to
engage in a pattern of degrading and
abusive behavior
which belittled these employees
undermine their value and work
damaged their reputations more broadly
throughout the rcmp
and caused them significant distress and
mental suffering
the group says by early 2017 nearly half
of the original national intelligence
coordination center analysts had left
because they couldn't handle the stress
of working under ortis
but the trio says the most damaging
revelation came when they learned the
intelligence that mr ortiz had stolen
and sold included their work and they
were told investigators believe
ort has systematically targeted them and
attacked their careers as part of his
larger plan to misappropriate their work
and use it for personal gain i think
there's a larger issue that comes out of
this case which is
had these allegations of harassment been
addressed sooner by rcmp management
would it have been possible for them to
catch cameron ortiz sooner
and prevent all the damage that he may
have indeed caused
the employees raised red flags
consistently over several years they say
the rcmp
eventually launched a review in december
2019
after ortiz's arrest a redacted version
included in the lawsuit showed
a failure of leadership at all levels of
senior management but the lawsuit
alleges
no action has been taken we take these
reports extremely seriously and i can
assure you that minister blair
is following up on them and looking into
what may have happened around around
this case neither blair's office the
rcmp nor ortiz's lawyer commented by
deadline
each plaintiff is seeking at least 1.9
million dollars in damages
and a security source unconnected to the
lawsuit confirms to global news
employees raised concerns about ortiz
behavior
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the toppling of a statue of sir john a
mcdonald has reignited the debate over
how to honor canada's first prime
minister
politicians of all stripes condemn the
act of vandalism
some warning about erasing history but
mcdonald's legacy includes implementing
the residential school system
jamie dahl looks at the delicate balance
of preserving history while coming to
terms with a racist past
painted and protested over the weekend
this monument of canada's first prime
minister came crashing down
once again in montreal
while some celebrated others like
alberta's premier jason kenney
jumped on twitter ready to rescue the
monument and place it on the legislature
grounds in edmonton
it was violence against a public
property
against a symbol of canada
i will offer to take it off their hands
at no cost to them and to reassemble it
and
and securely install it and protect it
and defend it i don't see it as a
fruitful next step in reconciliation
there are at least ten statues of sir
john a macdonald across the country
many of them have been vandalized over
the years and last year the city of
victoria
voted to remove one and there are
schools named after him too
this calgary teacher says it's time to
correct the story and the legacy of the
first leader
of this country his tool of genocide was
schools
so to name a school after him might
it tells me that we are definitely not
telling the story correctly
because to memorialize someone who used
schools as a weapon to kill the indian
and the child
in sir johnny mcdonald's own words well
that just means that we really don't
care about the actions that he did in
context
sure you want to put a statue up okay
tell the story on monday quebec's
premier announced the statue in montreal
will be
restored we may have discussions in the
next years about
changes but right now the decision
is that it will be re-put in place those
discussions
can't come soon enough according to some
tearing down the statues doesn't change
anything in particular but
if it provides us with a moment to
become
more deliberate and reflective and to
listen
better and to work hard together to make
legitimate decisions that honestly
reckon with our
our past and our identity
that's why that's why it happens because
we haven't done it
and he says until the country does
reckon with its past
statues will continue to be pulled down
jamie dahl global news calgary
accusations against the central figure
in hotel rwanda
coming up a man once hailed a hero faces
criminal charges
history unfolded in the middle east
today with the first commercial flight
from israel to the united arab emirates
it's a major step in warming up
relations between the two countries
after agreeing to a surprise u.s
brokered peace deal
the uae is just the third arab state to
establish diplomatic ties with israel
but the pact has yet to be signed and as
redmond shannon reports
there is one contentious hurdle to clear
calling passengers for abu dhabi a
boarding announcement
never heard before in israel
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
greeted travellers too
the plane carrying u.s and israeli
officials
headed on a flight path that's also new
to israeli jets
through saudi arabian airspace i think
that all of this is hopefully a
manifestation of
what is possible in the middle east then
touchdown
for the star of david on emirates soil
assurances of middle east stability
didn't extend to the microphone
speaking in arabic israel's national
security adviser invited
other arab nations to join the uae in
normalizing relations with israel
this is really a non-event a non-event
portrayed as a major event it's a
non-event because it just an
officialization
of ongoing relations with a common foe
of iran
israel and the uae had been cooperating
for years
even reportedly on military exercises
but that is where problems could still
arise before the deal is signed in
washington
the uae was expecting that this would be
a green light for them to
acquire f-35 planes from the u.s
israel fears that could signal a
military
power shift towards its new friend in
the gulf
palestinian prime minister mohammed
shtaya called it a painful day
again lamenting what he sees as a
betrayal
by an arab ally this deal coming just
months after washington's
israeli-palestinian peace plan
that had no palestinian involvement
redmond shannon global news
london lebanon's leaders have appointed
the country's relatively unknown
ambassador to germany
to form its new government mustafa adeeb
who is affiliated with a small sunni
party
won the support of lebanon's major
political parties he says he hopes to
form government in record time
in his first move as prime minister
designate adi
visited one of the area's hardest hit by
the deadly beirut explosion
he's promising to speed up the
investigation and get more financial
help to rebuild
adeeb's new designation came hours
before french president emmanuel macron
arrived to visit
and pressed for major reforms to end
lebanon's political and economic
crises the man who inspired the
hollywood film hotel rwanda
is being held on terror charges tonight
paul russo-savagina saved hundreds of
lives
sheltering people inside the luxury
hotel he managed during rwanda's 1994
genocide
he was awarded america's presidential
medal of freedom a year later
he's a staunch critic of rwanda's
long-serving president who is accused of
silencing his opponents
narussa sabagena is charged with
terrorism murder
and kidnapping and is accused of leading
terror groups
still ahead conflicting campaigns trump
and biden
butt heads over a divided america
the candidates for the white house are
hitting the campaign trail despite the
surge in cases of kova 19.
today's debate centers around the
protests over racial injustice
democrat joe biden took aim at donald
trump saying the u.s president is
driving division to shift the focus away
from the pandemic
as jennifer johnson reports trump is
planning to visit kenosha wisconsin
the epicenter of the latest protests
[Music]
a divided america as clashes break out
between pro-trump demonstrators
and those calling for an end to racial
injustice
the two presidential candidates are
clashing too president trump calls black
lives matter demonstrators
thugs and anarchists democratic
candidate joe biden wants police reform
and an end to the violence donald trump
has been a toxic
presence in our nation for four years
fires are burning and we have a
president who fans the flames
rather than fighting the flames you know
what i say protesters your ass
they're not protesters
biden says trump is desperate to turn
america's attention
away from the covet 19 pandemic trump
says he wants law and order
and plans tuesday to visit law
enforcement officers in kenosha
wisconsin
after a police involved shooting of a
black man ignited days of fury
right now is not the time presidents and
are always welcome in the community but
the timing i think is not
really a very good timing the president
is also waging a twitter war against
portland oregon's mayor
calling him a fool and a dummy after 95
straight nights of protests
and threatening to send in the national
guard either the president support us
or you stay the hell out of the way both
sides say voters in november will have a
clear choice on america's future
most of donald trump's america is
peaceful we are not safe in donald
trump's america
racial inequality is taking center stage
as the candidates fight for votes
and push very different agendas for a
more peaceful
america jennifer johnson global news
washington up next how to pick the right
protection for kids
heading back to the classroom
september is at our doorstep and most
students are either back in school
or getting ready to go besides the usual
notebooks and pencils many kids will be
required to return to school with masks
the rules vary from province to province
but how to pick the right one
jeff semple looks into that tonight
stephanie clayton was born with a
chronic illness and compromised immune
system
she spent much of her life in hospital
wearing a mask
they're the surgical masks so they
weren't the most comfortable
so she started making her own with more
comfortable
cotton and custom designs i always
wanted one that kind of reflected my
personality
and wasn't super ugly and like looked
like i
belonged in a hospital and suddenly
she's not alone
in the final hours of back to school
shopping many are now scrambling to
purchase this year's must-have
accessory and retailers are getting
creative
this high-end clothing store's top kid
seller
masks with emojis child psychologists
say
these goofy designs are no joke so i
think
really engaging our children and you
know sort of like deciding and choosing
the one that they like
is a great idea this toronto shop offers
a wide range of fabrics and designs from
bamboo with room for a filter
to lightweight polyester the trick for
parents is balancing comfort
with adequate protection evidence
suggests material from scarves or
bandanas
is only slightly better than wearing no
mask at all the government recommends at
least two layers of tightly woven cotton
or linen
i think a two-layer cotton mask which is
a very common design that's
that's being sold quite widely
is really a a good compromise it's
comfortable against the skin and it
tends to be quite breathable
online ads depict happy masked families
though many parents believe this meme
better captures the reality
this isn't the mask you wore to school
the mother says no this one
is way cooler i think it's going to be
difficult
clayton is now producing custom masks
for her fellow students
and donating them to local charities if
you can
find a mask that suits you it definitely
makes it more comfortable to wear
jeff semple global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is silver birch beach
in toronto we would love to see your
corner of this country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Applause]
[Music]
you